le génie industriel a été longtemps la
marque de fabrique de la france avec de
grands champions dont les français
étaient fiers genêts d'or alcatel
pechiney alstom thompson et autres
framatome malheureusement nous sommes
aujourd'hui victimes d'un véritable
décrochage industriels la part de
l'industrie dans la richesse nationale
est tombée à un niveau historiquement
bas à 11%
face à cette situation le sentiment que
donne le gouvernement c'est de ne pas
avoir pris la mesure de ce drame
comment par exemple avoir pu soutenir
leurs achats d'ascq ovale par british
style sans s'être renseigné sur la bonne
santé financière du repreneur
comment avoir accepté l'absortion dastum
par gerda électrique une entreprise
incapable aujourd'hui de tenir ses
engagements en matière d'emploi
comment se résoudre à voir disparaître
l'ex usine où elle coule à amiens malgré
les promesses présidentielles
comment comprendre monsieur le premier
ministre que vous allez bientôt
augmenter les impôts des entreprises
pour financer les mesures annoncées est
la suite des mouvements de gilet jaune
alors que celle-ci supporte déjà 100
milliards de prélèvements de toutes
sortes de plus que leurs concurrents de
la zone euro comme le disait le général
de gaulle la politique la plus ruineuse
la plus coûteuse c'est celle d'être
petit alors monsieur le premier ministre
où sont les mesures que les français
attendent pour enfin favoriser
l'investissement et la modernisation de
l'entreprise france l'industrie
française élément essentiel de notre
souveraineté
alors monsieur le premier quand allez
vous enfin avoir la france en grand et
mettre en place une politique
industrielle ambitieuse pour redonner
aux français leur fierté
l'annoncé par general electric la
semaine dernière d'un plan social massif
qui concerne près de 1050 emploi a été
un vrai coup de massue pour notre
département
l'entreprise n'a pas respecté ses
engagements de créer 1000 emplois et
pire encore elle s'apprête à supprimer
autant les conséquences sur l'économie
sur les sous-traitants les artisans et
les commerçants sont considérables dans
un département de 150000 habitants et
sur un site industriel vieux de 140 ans
ce plan social n'est pas acceptable
vous êtes venu ce lundi à belfort
monsieur le ministre pour rencontrer sur
le site de ji
les représentants des salariés et les
élus locaux au cours d'une réunion que
je qualifierais de constructive et au
cours de laquelle chacun a pu développer
ses analyses et proposer des solutions à
cette situation
jy communique depuis plusieurs mois sur
l'absence d'avenir du marché de la
turbine à gaz qui est certes en baisse
mais qui connaît une activité cyclique
et qui pourrait être en phase de rebond
très prochainement notamment parce
qu'elles sont utiles pour compenser les
pertes de charge des énergies
renouvelables or autant de suppressions
de poste met en danger les sites de
belfort et de bourogne en raison de la
perte des compétences et de savoir-faire
le samedi 22 juin prochain belfort se
mobilisera à nouveau aux côtés des
salariés de dgi pour défendre notre
savoir faire et nos emplois soyez
assurés que nous lâcherons rien aussi
monsieur le ministre
ma question est très simple comment
l'état compte s'engager à nos côtés
comme l'italie de salvini la france ne
respecte pas ses engagements européens
en ne réduisant pas son déficit
structurel comme l'italie de salvini la
france ont choisi de baisser les impôts
en aggravant les déficits comme l'italie
de salvini la france un haut niveau de
chômage réel est structurel
les mêmes causes produisant les mêmes
effets comme l'italie de salvini vous
choisissez la dette au risque de faire
porter et je cite le fmi une menace
inquiétante sur notre pays
alors madame la ministre pensez-vous
avoir raison seul contre toutes les
institutions dont nous sommes membres
pensez vous que la bonne politique
économique soit celle de monsieur
salvini l'homophobie a désormais un ou
plutôt des visages ces regards effarés
ces figures tuméfié ses pommettes
défense et ses lèvres fendues à la gare
de sartrouville samedi dernier un couple
de femmes a été agressé à paris
un chauffeur ne supporte pas que deux
hommes s'embrassent à l'arrière de son
véhicule allie le poitiers et besançon
lyon et en d'autres endroits encore des
femmes et des hommes sont menacés
insultés et parents mettent parfois même
frappé parce qu'ils sont homosexuels
et si l'homophobie ne se mesure pas
seulement avec des chiffres il donne
malheureusement le vertige et provoque
au delà du simple malaise un profond
écoeurement
en un an le nombre de signalements
d'actes homophobes est en hausse de 15%
pire les seuls agressions physiques
augmentent de 60 6%
car il nous faut lutter chaque jour pied
à pied contre toute forme d'homophobie
non pas seulement avec des mots mais
aussi et surtout avec des actes alors
quand ce dispositif sera t-il
réalité car ces femmes et ces hommes
sont eux aussi le visage de la france
monsieur le ministre en juillet 2018
votre prédécesseur au ministère de la
transition écologique et solidaire
m'avait précisé l'attachement de l'état
à prendre la mesure des dangers que
courent les populations riveraines de
décharge de déchets dangereux et
polluants enfouis dans des sites
abandonnés et dont plus personne n'est
responsable
les acteurs à l'origine de
l'enfouissement et ont tous disparu
moralement comme physiquement dans un
contexte plus global de nécessaire
préservation de l'environnement et de
nos paysages
qu'entendez vous faire pour résorber les
pollutions de ces sites dont les
traitements mis en oeuvre jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ne sont plus adaptés à nos
exigences environnementales du 21e
siècle près de 900 mille jeunes sont
inscrits sur la plateforme parcours sup
parmi ces lycéens et ses étudiants très
peu sont informés que les données
personnelles qu'ils saisissent alimente
une base de données cette base de
données or isup contient de manière très
détaillée l'ensemble du parcours
scolaire universitaire du candidat ses
données personnelles et familiales dont
les revenus bruts des parents quasiment
toutes ces données sont conservées et
exploités durant quinze ans par des
chercheurs
elles sont supposées n'avoir qu'une
finalité statistique est inacceptable
madame la ministre que l'arrêté portant
création de riz sup n'impose pas
l'accord exprès du candidat sur
l'utilisation des données personnelles
[Musique]